tu
e
ma plus belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélas
pascal obispo qui verra le voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la neoma sur scène
la rue mathieu ce mois-là soit ça où tu
m'as s'écroule joue de nous sans trop
savoir pourquoi regarder devant soi sans
jamais baisser les bras
je sais c'est pas un remède à tous mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais tu es mon
fils et ma plus belle année
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma plus belle
[Musique]
pour se lever
je me tenais
[Applaudissements]
je suis jamais
peut-être
[Musique]
cours de danse à 19h40 jusqu'à 19h40 et
non se retrouve juste
mathieu bat mathieu c'est moi tu sais il
ya des soirs comme ça où tout
s'écroule autour de nous
sans trop savoir pourquoi toujours
regardez devant soir
n'ont jamais baissé les bras je sais
je suis pas le remède à tous et un deux
et trois satellites alors mais faut
savoir c'est parfois mathieu mathieu
dépêche toi on vit
on ne meurt qu'une fois
[Musique]
et on n'a toujours rien
c'est déjà la fin mais c'est pas marqué
dans les livres
que plus important à vivre c'est de
vivre au jour le jour
autant c'était l'amour
[Musique]
nous en portant un livre c'est le niveau
au jour le jour
le temps
semana
ces deux-là mois
parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]